well when I was working in to disney
studios I really felt that you know that
that dizzy used to be like the place
where technology in the incredible
advances in technology were combined
with artistry to really advance the
story telling of animation and I felt
like it really reached a plateau with
with 101 dalmatians you know in the
sense that here was a Xerox technology
that was that was added to the the art
form that really what made it a able for
all the image to do a hundred and one
different Dalmatians and and but
everything after that though that there
was moments of really greatness in the
artistry and stuff the technology really
kind of reached a certain plateau and I
always felt like there was something
kind of something more and I started
seeing you know the tapes coming back
from the the siggraph conferences you
know they would kind of release tapes
and it was really interesting what was
going on but but it was really you know
it became really good friends with Bill
crore and Bill and Jerry Reese were
working on storyboarding doing the
choreography all the computer animation
on Tron and I didn't work on toronto's
working on Mickey's Christmas Carol at
the time and they get invited me to come
to they were in a little trailer kind of
right next to the volleyball court and
we would kind of poke our heads in there
and see what was going on and I remember
when they got some of the very first
dailies on 35 millimeter film from Chris
wedge at Magi sent a vision of the light
cycle sequence was one of the first
things they did they we threaded up on
one of these ancient movie ola's that
you know helped make snow white and it
was really like this moment and when I
saw that that was my aha moment I think
we all it was interesting hearing from
the first panel everybody's aha moments
and that was mine to see because when we
were going to calarts I wouldn't went
from 75 79 in the first year the
character animation program and and you
need to see the the incredible
advancement American filmmaking you know
with with Coppola and Spielberg and
Lucas and you know and then the shining
came out Raging Bull in 1980 you knows
with Scorsese it was like amazing stuff
going on the invention of the Steadicam
you know and how could you forget the
shining you know and following that guy
on that big wheel you know through that
huge hotel you know the and just what
the camera work was doing and when I saw
that sequence from the light cycle
sequence it was like wow we could do
steady camp shots in animation you know
and and I just started getting so
excited about talking to Bill and Jerry
and then and then talking to glen keane
a lot about it and then from there we
were able to to do a Tom will hide his
head of live-action production at the
time he he had he let Glen and I do a
test using Maurice index K characters of
Max from where the wild things are they
were in development at the time we did
this test working with magi syntha
vision we did the the wild things test
which was hand hand drawn character
animation with computer computer
generated backgrounds all digital ink
and paint with tone mats and this was in
1981 and it was it was really exciting
you know and then I got fired
you